yo yo yo what it do man it's your boy
Pusher ride here with my dog G Bracken
yeah we on on on a bootleg Kev podcast
man this a bootleg ass [__] himself he
can't even say it right we on a ble C
podcast you feel me [__] with us f with
about to get into another interview
brought to you by my bookie it's holiday
season that means bowl games NBA
inseason tournament NFL all going down
let's make this money right now if you
sign up at my bookie and use my promo
code bootleg claim your deposit match
that's right put deposit in up to $1,000
they're going to match it
mybookie.ag promo code is bootleg let's
get to the
interview Bole C podcast man we got some
special guests in the building Pusher
Rod hell yeah hell yeah gutter Bracken
is
here what's up man man you know man just
honored to be here Kev how you been
brother I'm good brother so tell me why
you well this your artist right here
right he's he's making noise in the city
yeah this my young [__] gutter Bracken
um he's out here doing his thing he got
a project on the way just trying to come
you know start it off right shake some
hands kiss some babies let everybody
know who I'm [__] with right now and
we have a freestyle coming Yeah Yeah he
talking that [__] for sure for sure man
uh for people who don't know who you are
Rod obviously you've been a part
of Pusher for people who don't know push
Inc the label is kind of what introduced
the world to YG Tha dollar sign you go
on on right yeah so you've been a part
give me your history like cuz you've
been with Y from the the beginning yeah
you go back to any Y video I'm in every
video I've been with bro since the
beginning I known him since we like 12
years old right so you um like kind of
give me like like a rundown of just kind
of like your history with him like did
it when when it comes to the music
industry yeah so like on the music
industry side I like to call myself a
professional homie um from the way that
I started off with YG because at the
beginning I I was doing anything I was
answering phone calls I was passing out
flyers I was giving out mixtapes I was
driving to shows I'm driving across the
state to different shows whatever it
took to my homies get to the next level
that's what I was on so I wouldn't call
myself like a day-to-day assistant or
assistant you were like a utility knife
professional whatever you need me to do
whatever you need you feel me got to
beat somebody up I'm n for that too um
yo it's crazy too because I think a lot
of people don't really like um people
know YG outside of La is just like YG
he's been around for so long but like
the like early y mixtape era was like I
I didn't live in LA at the time I think
at the time that was going on I was
living in
Vegas but I heard it was just like crazy
yeah that was different era that was a
different time man we had these streets
at La really in a choke code and
honestly it was just about unity and
trying to bring people together we had
this park we used called push a Park
which is stalker park that's on like Le
and stalker and we just used to invite
everybody from the city up there to come
[__] with the pushes and it's like if
you up here and you [__] with us if
you got an issue with somebody y'all
going to handle that was this like kind
of like running simultaneously with the
jerk era or towards the end of the jerk
era you talking about um B J yeah I'm
know that guy no no no I'm not even
saying that I said the jerk era it was
an era of la music of course I'm saying
like cuz I feel like you guys kind of
like like came like you know it's so
crazy because um a lot of the [__] I was
doing just vanj catching a stray I
didn't even I didn't even say the new I
seen bro on Instagram talking [__] like
week ago and it's like bro I didn't even
know shout out to him I didn't know he
was a thing still he's not yeah wasn't
he [__] t no it was the other one
Legacy shout out Legacy yeah good for
him man was that the lightskinn one yeah
yeah the lightskinn one was taking down
Tas yeah crazy because like for a while
Legacy like put new boy [__] on a back
burner to focus on tanas in her career
right before she took off it's like some
crazy St boys were way for a sec bro you
go to [__] Legacy was a wave you could
go to Hot Topic and get a [__] new
shirt he was producing rapping he was
like they introduce them tight colorful
jeans to the world bro them things was
tight them tight jeans boy list it was a
little different you know but no but so
like like the push ink [__] was like
bubbling I feel like at the tail end of
that and then you guys kind of took it
it was really all around the same time
like when I was in high school that's
like when jerking was cracking um and I
used to throw parties I used to do this
thing called club kids with like Twan
whiz kid Casey and we used to throw like
these high school parties and had like
two three th000 kids come weekend yeah
we gave the new boys they first show
Cali Swag District they first show like
a lot of artist audio push out a little
way going shout out to price yeah shout
out to price that's the Octan yeah yeah
yeah so um when did you guys realize
that like what you were doing was like
actually starting to kind of like you
know work bro I'll be lying to you don't
realize [__] is a movement into it's
like already start almost over almost
exact you don't even realize you're
living through history until you look
back back you start sitting down talking
about the things y did and things like
that like damn we really just changed
the culture but we didn't even know what
we were doing change the culture we were
just trying to have fun and put out
music like like for a long time La was
like kind of like a No Man's Land a
little dead zone so it was like we
wanted people to respect what we were
talking about what we were bringing so
like in order to get the respect of the
world you got to get it in your backyard
first so like we made sure we had to
respect in LA to make sure we go to
these other places everybody championed
us who was uh like the first push a Inc
like was it Ty or was it YG who was kind
of the the founding three members is Ace
Obama YG PC okay and then Tai became a
part of it yeah later on Big B rest in
peace Big B Big B brought in Tai and he
brought in mustard oh [__] is it true
Mustard's first beat ever was Patty Cake
yeah bro cuz he told me that was the
first be he ever made no cap like
mustard didn't used to produce he was a
DJ but bro for a long time and this
before I was an anr like why you mustard
was so tired of everybody sending them
the same beat over and over over and
over it's like everybody was trying to
put him into a certain box or certain
type of Style music and they were trying
to figure out how to get out of it so
mustard ducked off paid attention for a
while him and Mike free created a sound
like Mike free actually taught must how
to produce right people don't know that
yeah Mike free is a very
underrated guy in La M for sure but yeah
no um and then mustard just took what
Mike free gave him and just enhanced
that to the next level cuz he he
understood it from a different realm
like you're a DJ you know like no you
you know what to what what to make to
make people dance exactly and what you
looking for for a certain type of hour
in that party and it's like I feel like
that's where a lot of producers are
slacking now for sure cuz they're like
just stuck in the house playing fortnite
jerking off and making beats around no
energy no nothing they just making on a
computer watching porn but it's like she
ain't really in your face shaking ass
how you feel
it damn um so obviously uh for you
you've turned being a professional homie
into being an anr at inter scope for Te
inter scope for about I was at inter
scope for about 8 years while I was
there I signed people like money bag yo
Rich the kid um Aaron Ray did drez's
first album Mi Dre's hard super slept on
man it was her first out Mitch shout out
to Mitch that's my guy that's my a homie
man bro Mitch out here killing it Mitch
is incredible and every time I see his
Instagram it makes me feel really bad
about my my body man Mitch just had a
baby shout out
toch Mitch man shout out to Mitch Mitch
is a real one very slept on artist he he
killed what's it the red tape the [__]
has I know oh my God yeah hey that's
like lowkey like might be like my second
favorite y album that's on Spotify
that's fire the red tape is so good red
tape was just a Vibe it was fun it
wasn't it was no bars no like he was
just having fun with music that [__] was
hard shout out to uh to to the homie Jay
waves too be over there with Mitch man
repping a man shout out to those guys um
so yeah so so when you say cuz a lot of
people don't understand what anr does
and when they say well you signed
somebody to the label give us like a
like what does that mean exactly so like
um you you look for talent you search
and you find Talent then you try to
bring that talent to the label and then
you try to help that artist who already
had some going get to that next level or
understand themsel more understand like
what's the message that they trying to
feed off to the world like and it's so
[__] up cuz I feel like it's not a lot
of real anrs no more because everybody
want to sign somebody that's already on
that's already lit based off analytics
versus you going to find an artist you
believe in are you finding somebody when
it's first starting like oh I can see
the trajectory or where that can go like
for me is I've never signed an artist
who had like a crazy ass deal where
every lab was fighting for him I fought
for the artist who I personally believed
in yeah it's like whoever the anr is at
uh I won't even say never mind bad
example well not a bad example but I
won't say but yes you're right like hey
congratulations you signed that tick
tocker yeah or just like you know
[__] if you signed sexy red con rats
she's the hottest [__] alive man shout
out gamma shout out to gamma gamma's
[__] they got
Usher and they got Rick Ross listen and
they got French Montana listen Jackson
he
knows putting it together over there
respect to everything he's doing that
again 100% man I sexy red I didn't that
see that was a bad example but yeah like
yeah sign sexy red of
course you know whyg got a new single
dropping with sexy red real soon stay
tuned that's saw they shot the video how
was it having a pregnant sexy red in the
hood over there bro that [__] honestly
bro I ain't been a bomed in a minute
like with with the pregnant hottest
chick on the planet yeah and it was like
[__] we was over there we pulled up
first I got sent an address I get sent
the address pull up to this house ain't
nobody there I'm like what the [__] is
going on calling everybody Denny like
[__] we in the alley [__] go to the
alley [__] all you see is [__] red
everywhere oh wow all right I'm
comfortable now all right where the
homies at but it was cool it was a dope
video um the home girl n she's from La
she does um sexy red styling and [__] so
shout out to her um sexy red came
through and it's crazy cuz she's still
humble and you appreciate that like
people get to normal as [__] exactly
gang I [__] with it she put up in Crocs
no Crocs she like [__] y'all got my
y'all showing my feet well if y'all
ain't showing my feet I ain't putting
these heels on I said you got it yeah no
she came and did my club and Crocs last
week oh God like I I [__] I [__] with
her energy like a lot of people say a
lot of things um I respect anything
that's Au she authentic as [__] ex you
feel me like that's like if that's she's
an apologetically herself exactly and
that's five it's not an image or nothing
it's like at she just that's who she is
like you [__] with it you [__] with it
you don't she don't give a [__] that's
why she's winning I wish more people
would like that 100% for you being
somebody from LA and being a part of
like YG's crew who's in my opinion the
biggest La rapper we've had in since the
game I mean or nip obviously I think nip
got the flowers nationally worldwide
unfortunately once he passed but YG is
like the face of La rap since it was the
game and then y is how I look at it you
know what I'm saying um what do you
think has been the disconnect as to why
there isn't more Superstars out of La I
feel like the disconnect for La is and
by the way DOA cat's from La shout out
DOA cat do sometimes we be
just N I literally was having this
conversation the Bigg I was having this
conversation with gut the other the
night like shout out DOA she from the
city um but I feel like a lot of us we
get too scared to move outside the box
or think outside the box and we from La
[__] get rich and move here [__] get
rich and they want to come to Hollywood
Hills it's like when you from LA and you
get rich where do you go Vegas save the
tax money save the tax money not at all
but it's like so I feel like it's a hard
it's a hard pill to swallow there but
more artists from here just need to get
out and try different things and try to
go [__] with people on the other side of
the world because when the artist in
Detroit get cracking in Detroit you see
him in Detroit you see him in Atlanta
you see him in New York and then you see
him come to La out here two three months
for we get cracking oh yeah we doing a
tour from San Diego to [__]
Washington the Phoenix maybe you know
and then maybe Albuquerque and then
we're going to try to do that same tour
and three months 6 months but these
other people from these other bro
they're trying and they're getting out
of state so to every La artist out there
and RI tell you bro like me Andi argue
about this all the time get the [__] out
of La go see some [__] go move around
you are the lifestyle yeah Ruchi needs
to move to Atlanta for like a year hey
man I might move back to Atlanta for a
year shout out to RCI man I love RI man
Rie is a one of them ones facts for sure
shout out to Roo big roach dog the guy
travels with a bong oh G yo he the only
person I know still smokes sers and it's
crazy well he's the only person I know
that has a bong with him every backpack
everywhere everywhere I'm like bro
why and ain't even a small bong this
[__] got a three-foot bung on
him at all times like moving around like
it's like cheich and Chong [__] it's
it's crazy um yeah I think the other
thing too do you feel like
um do you feel like another thing La has
going against it is that there's so many
politics in the streets that maybe at
times can prevent artists from working
together I I don't I don't believe that
and the reason why I say I don't believe
that is cuz look pay attention to Y and
nip right they moved around together
everybody you can say what you like I'm
not the most educated on all of the
street politics did
YG did his neighborhood beef with
nipsey's neighborhood though it's Bloods
and Crips right but I think that like as
it don't matter it's still like that's
what I'm saying like people get too
jaded or too lost in [__] is like but
isn't it more in La cuz I do think that
the outsider perspective of Bloods and
Crips from LA are if it's a blood or a
[__] is beef when there
are blood sets that beef with blood sets
[__] sets that beef I mean the biggest
[__] in La is like the Hoovers versus
the 60s you know what I'm saying like
and they're technically it's not a blood
vers [__] thing so I guess like that I
think with YG and nip was it a little
easier for them to nah I don't think it
was I don't think so because it's like
even if it wasn't YG it's about the
people we be around with right cuz why a
blood he hang out with all Bloods a [__]
he hang around with a lot of different
Crips a lot of different neighborhood
[__] cards right so I'm from swans nip
might have been having some people from
East Coast with him or like YG got
homies like baby Dot from Inwood
families and nip might have so and so
from 90 with like it's like I really
believe like so they kind of show people
it's bigger than the program I really
believe everything is bigger than the
program it's how you look at it like if
you going to part of that program like
shout out to you go be that but if you a
man first and you carry yourself like a
man no matter what Hood you from what
Hood you in people going to respect you
like I don't be in my my enemies Hood
like doing no stupid [__] but bro like
people see me move around La 9 time not
10 I'm by myself or with one other
person I'm not traveling around with 30
[__] but everybody in La know where
I'm from but it's how I carry myself as
a man I feel like and a lot of people
don't understand how to carry their self
like a man are really be scary so they
only move around when they move around
with they hood or they only talk when
they got 30 [__] with them but it's
like [__] I done pulled up to the 60's
to go meet nip or BH by myself I done
pulled up on 60th and Madden to meet BH
by myself for me and YG we don't need 30
[__] but it's like if BH came to the
east side to the swans he going to have
the same respect like I done had like
bro you got to think like back in the
day bro we shot a video y shot a video
in the schoolyard Hood TC from
schoolyard but we had the jungles there
the swans there how's shout out TC man
TC is great man that's my brother we
were literally just talking [__] on on
DM like the morning before last um but
yeah bro it's like I think it's more in
the person and how the person got
respect in their neighborhood and how
they carryed themselves like if your
homies respect you your homies going to
respect whoever you bring over there but
if your homies look at you like a mark
[__] when you bring somebody over there
they going to show that you the mark
right like and I feel like that's what
La is really is like of course there's
gang [__] of course there's politics but
everything comes as a man or as a woman
how you respect yourself I just feel
like other cities don't have that extra
lay everyone's got hoods and everyone's
got problems like you know [__] no bro
that's that but that' be the smoking
mirror but I feel like even like Detroit
like it used to be the East Side versus
West Side thing which is still obviously
issues with a lot of people in Detroit
but a lot of that [__] got put to the
side now you're seeing people from
Detroit work together that would never
have worked also seeing other people get
in the middle of it like [__] I'm not
standing for that like Skiller baby
[__] Skiller baby with s baby and F
with t Grizz I'm not going to be in the
middle of that I'mma squash it cuz I'm a
real [__] I I respect both of y'all SK
and I feel like if more artists or more
people carried themselves like that
you'll see less [__] like that but bro
like people I hear it all the time like
La Gang This La gang that but it's like
bro there's gangs everywhere if I go to
Atlanta I'm not going to the south side
of Atlanta by myself if I don't know
nobody from the south side of Atlanta
who's going to move around with me I'm
not scary no but you're not stupid I'm
not stupid yeah I got I got $100,000
worth of jewelry on why am I going to
[__] hang out in Harlem well we
should we should uh we should leave that
jewelry at home man no I'm just don't go
to Atlanta with 100 Grand of jewelry but
that's what I'm saying but don't go to
Atlanta with 100 Grand of jewelry but
the Atlanta come to LA with 100 Grand
and jury get robbed like come on bro it
I feel like it goes same for St whatever
state whatever city you in if you got
respect for sure and if you move you
just got to move the right way man
exactly so how did you find uh gut
Bracken Man actually we from the same
area I'm from 77th Street he from 84th
Street though you know but all blocks is
the same we out the swans um I've been
KN bro for a while um I've been seeing
him rap for a while but I never wanted
to be that person who like oh yeah I'm a
sign I'mma put on my Young Homie or
young [__] from my hood to make sure
like bro that [__] corny like I care
about music and I care about art and I
saw this young [__] actually care about
his music and care about art when I
opened my studio two years ago um I
opened the doors up to like five or six
of the my young homies or not even my
young homies my homies from my hood um
and told them look bro I got a studio
the doors open if we ain't booked come
record you can come record any day I got
four rooms I know all four ain't going
to be booked every day all you got to do
is bring your own engineer I give you a
free room bring your own engineer but
this [__] he record himself he shoot
videos he edit videos he does c art he
does anything digital anything you ask
him to do for his own career he can do
it so you're saving a lot of money hell
yeah not just saving a lot of money he
understands saving a lot of money he he
understands himself as a brand and if
you can't get his brand right he'll
figure out how he'll figure out his own
brand right and that made me [__] with
bro a lot more you're editing your own
videos and stuff if the editor don't get
it right I'm editing my own video every
time not every time look that's so
important though cuz like name one video
I got out that I didn't edit but you had
an editor but you you added to the
editor I edited he technically Ed I bet
you got that the credit I just let's
give gutter his roses today it's
important cuz you know reals and YouTube
shorts and all this [__] is so important
it's like if you if you don't know how
to edit your own [__] like that then
you're [__] way behind exactly if you
got to wait for another person to send
you a little re for your IG or your your
[__] your YouTube short then like bro
what are you doing like hello there's no
excuses either I know I at first though
I didn't know how to work Tik Tok or
none of that [__] I used to be on my ass
like bro that's some [__] you really got
to get into because if you don't do that
[__] like you you're not going to follow
with the algorithm on me so I had to get
into that [__] too that [__] was crazy
it's important man it's it's like people
I think people used to fight Tik Tok cuz
it came off like a corny thing to do
yeah but now it's like you got if you
get it it's great same thing with
YouTube shorts and reals it's all the
same [__] bro it's all I mean you just
got to get into that algorithm and keep
putting shots up fact what up y'all
bootleg Kev here shout out to our family
at Imperial extraction listen right now
oh a free two G pre roll of that zah of
that loud of that gas can get right to
your door delivered for free now this is
what's dope about Imperial let me tell
you man the thing about Imperial is they
got 16 years of experience when it comes
to this West Coast cannabis space and
recently they just got into the hemp
scene now what is the hemp scene that
means uh that it's it's legal it's going
to get delivered right to your door
federally legal it ships to your door no
issues uh and this is what also is dope
about it it's still going to get you
high it's going to get you blown just
like that uh traditional cannabis it's
that
thca um look they got so much stuff
going on um this is the thcp enhanced
live resin you can get your carts there
they got all the flavors boom boom most
importantly whatever you do Imperial uh
make sure you go to their website
because uh look Imperial extraction. if
you go to that website and you use that
promo code bootleg you're going to get
hooked up with a free 2 Grand pre-roll
right now Imperial extraction. comom get
yourself I've been smoking these for uh
about 3 weeks now and man I love them
and um they definitely get me elevated
man and and this is what's dope about
these let me show yall just real quick
if you guys don't know um Imperial
extraction let's pop one open because
this is what's getting delivered to your
house for free remember imper
extraction. comom promo code bootleg at
checkout look at that thing man it's a
two G pre-roll with the glass tip
premium thca and it's got the diamond
infused uh joints in you bust this thing
open there's little diamonds in there
bro it's crazy all right it comes with 1
and2 gram of that top shelf flour half a
gram of the pure thca diamonds and uh
it's free yeah so uh go to the promo
code bootleg at Imperial extraction.
comom and trust me when I say you will
not regret it shout out to Imperial
extraction also want to give a shout out
to our good Folks at Blue Chu that's
right salute to the family at blueo make
sure you head on over to bluechew.com
use that promo code bootleg right now if
you don't know blue Cho where it's at
they're getting you situated real nicely
when it comes to your penis your Johnson
your
[__] that's a that's a weird way to who
says Co I don't know nonetheless if
you're dealing with the rectile
dysfunction if you're dealing with a
little anxiety little stress and you're
not up to par when it comes to
Performance look you need to put your
best step forward when it comes to your
dick game you know what I'm saying so
what you need to do is go to uh blue.com
use the promo code bootleg right now
they're going to give you a month supply
for free now if you're you're watching
this you don't know about blue Chu let
me explain same exact active ingredient
as Viagra and seales in a chewable form
deliver to your door discreetly yes no
doctor's appointments uh none of that
it's all online you don't have to worry
about going and sitting in an office and
waiting to go get your dick pills no
listen by the way these aren't dick
pills these are this is a chewable you
know what I'm saying let's just be clear
there's a difference this is much better
um blue.com promo code code bootleg
month supply for free delivered to your
door discreetly all online it's what
we're doing man same active ingredients
viagran SE Alice man get your dick right
all right let's get back to the
interview for sure so what do you uh
obviously you got music out I mean I've
been I've seen a lot of your [__] I was
just talking to the homie about you me
and head were talking about you like
three or four weeks ago we're just
talking about like new La guys um what G
give me kind of like what you got going
on right now uh right now I'm working on
a project well my project I just finish
my project but like that [__] crazy I
was working on that [__] for like a
whole year like that was my first time
working on a project that long um it got
the baby Stone gorillas on it and it got
earol suy rip uh it got other features
but I don't want to say no names it got
big features probably how big big big
yeah like a big like big Bank big not
big Bank big I after that I got feature
big bang big
probably um can he just cuz cuz of you
could he just get the white your feature
for free yeah but like it's about timing
it's about timing you hey you don't want
to get it just to get it you got to get
it when it's right that's what I told
that's what I told myself too though
like I don't I'm I'm not the type of
[__] that I know y he know y so it's
like it's nothing to Y yo it's so funny
cuz I work with artists and they're like
like hey man you you are you know so and
so I'm trying I'm like bro what the [__]
am I look like sending you sending your
record off to this you want me to cash
in that favor now or when you got some
real [__] going on me you want want the
artist to [__] with you like like on
your own it's going to happen on his own
yeah not just through a everything with
me is about being organic bro I ain't
get this far because I went to school I
ain't get this far because this or that
bro I got this far by being organic
really trust in the Vision Trust in my
plan staying dedicated and it's like
those are the things I'm trying to put
back in you got Mazy on your project nah
no okay I feel you shouted out Mazy in
the freestyle that I [__] I [__] I [__]
with Mazy yeah I hard but it's also part
about develop the artist is like all
right having an artist who developing
around artists who've made it or had
somewhat of level of success and having
him be able to have conversations in
regular places with them to understand
versus just oh yeah let's take a picture
for the gram like n these is my homies
going to come sit at the studio like bro
we had ASAP Ferg came out here from New
York came to hang with me [__] we only
talked for like 15 minutes he sat in the
studio with this [__] for like 3 hours
listen to his album listen to other
talking to him about being an artist
talking to him about coming to New York
and it's like that's the type of [__]
that I want bro to get I don't want oh
yeah I'm cool with Ferg so Ferg hop on
this song nah n it's going to happen
exactly yeah like I want the real [__]
so it's like when a fans see it and they
go do their research and go pay
attention like oh he deserve that not
just cuz he standing next to this ain't
no industry plant mhm I was going to ask
you like uh being a a there's there's a
lot of dope energy out of LA right now
yourself three know baby we talked about
got a big record for sure zama's killing
it like who's uh like who are who are
some of the upcoming La artists that you
just really like you know Kudos I see
what you're doing I'm a fan like maybe y
end up working together is any anybody
who comes to mind yeah baby Stone
gorillas they're on your project they're
killing it who p on my project uh I got
I got records with all the baby s on
gorillas though um Wally the Sensei I
love W Sensei W is amazing crazy um big
sad B big dope yo W is just like one
record away like like from like really
like he got a couple already but he's he
he's capable of just having a number
like yeah he's crazy yeah uh kin asash
yeah Kaylin's great uh I [__] with as
bash hey kayin Somebody went lived in
Atlanta for a little bit yeah he told me
and built with all the DJs in Florida
Atlanta and all that yeah yeah bro like
it's like when I be looking at this [__]
like bro when somebody trying to become
president
right for like two years straight they
going state to state city to City
shaking hands kissing babies doing all
this to be in your face so that you care
or you think that they care [__] you
got to treat your music the same way
like but we first came like bro when YG
went on tour with MC Miller oh yeah I
remember oh I got a couple of Y
incidents to ask you about we probably
had one song
he was not allowed to perform in Phoenix
though we not going to talk about that
oh we I was there I hosted the concert
listen I didn't have were you were there
that day yes I was there okay so I was
at the celebrity theater with a [__]
that was not my girl at the
time and I was I was I hosted this y
concert it's on
YouTube it's at the Celebrity Theater
it's the most struggle whack ass local
crooked ass promoters of all time cuz
they had 150 local artists opening up so
why is on so late bro like and it wasn't
even y'all's fault it was cuz there was
so many so when by the time YG gets on
the crowd is so annoyed pissed off like
I've never I've never saw a opener list
for a show it was insane after that y
sto like no I literally said guys you
guys got me [__] up if you think I'm
gonna walk out there and introduce all
these people like tell me I'll go on
stage three times I already got paid
nonetheless someone starts banging on in
the crowd throwing up some [__] that I
have I'm not privy to what it meant but
Y and mustard did not take too kindly to
it rest in peace slim 400 Slim 4 did not
take too kindly to it rest in peace and
then [__] just starts getting thrown and
at the time there's these metal laptop
stands called Uber stands that were very
heavy and DJ Mustard took the Uber stand
and I remember just seeing it like oh it
chucked it at somebody in the cow it was
was [__] insane it's on YouTube you
could go watch it it was a world a early
world star hit that's when I used to
have hair and at that time it kind of
[__] up Y in Phoenix bro just in
Phoenix bro that [__] [__] like this
be the thing people don't realize like
also I don't think a lot of people know
Las Vegas Metro wasn't [__] with Y
for a long time I still don't know if
they are by the way them incidents like
that last for so long like C CA cuz y
should have had a a residency by now in
Vegas but there's a reason why he hasn't
right he's he's not necessarily the Las
Vegas Metro don't look too fondly upon
at a certain point in time they have a
list shout out shout out to Las Vegas
well they have a list in Vegas shout out
to Dre shout out to no but there's a
list in Vegas the cops have a list so
mazy's on that list but why just because
of the game but you know it's so [__]
up cuz like even with the last [__] we
got banned from Vegas for like there's
no like I don't understand what what
this thing with fans like why a fan can
hurt harass you and get away with it
like and that's the part like of this
music industry like it's like you can
follow me for 20 minutes straight you
can call me all types of [__] all
types of hoes you can aggravate me [__]
you can stand that do whatever you want
to you can get in my face spit at me
whatever soon as I quote unquote as the
talent or as the ACT try to defend
myself then it's a lawsuit of course but
unfortunate like I don't I just don't
understand like you got gloves for if
gloves hit them it's still a lawsuit I
mean yeah I guess you're right look look
like gloves could just shake the [__]
out of somebody bro if gloves does this
somebody's going to the hospital hey I
got to ask you this question cuz you're
a Rams fan um shout out to Rams shout
out to Rams shout out to Rams I'm just
curious shout out the Rams yeah shout
out to the Rams but I'm just wondering
like what I appreciate about gloves is
like he never changed teams he's been a
Niner fan the whole time so let me
explain something to y'all man let's
talk about the ners right talk about the
ners Die Hard ner let's talk about the
ners right what what what did the ners
do to cernick what did the ners do to
crab tree what did the like what did
they do to crab tree they traded crab
tree when he was on bro we what you act
like Crabtree deserve not to get traded
he didn't deserve to get traded at that
overrated number one in the whole
[__] League he was the number one he
was he was a number three on a good
team what about our what what about the
running back at the time who you don't
even know his name were you a Niner fan
at the time I was going to them games
and [__] all the way listen I was going
to them games and [__] listen bro you
talk about Frank Gore yes Frank Gore
played there for like 12 Years bro what
do you mean what do you what do we
talking about talking about the ners man
as an organization just [__] just [__]
[__] ass organization shout out the Rams
all you got to do is say the Rams came
back to LA we're from La we changed
teams cuz that's what happened La all
day I'm a Rams fan yeah right okay hey
shout out to gloves gloves is a Niners
fan been that way the whole time look at
all gloves teams like he's a Clippers
fan he's [__] that's an original man no
original San Diego man no imagine
imagine being a Clippers fan right
that's amazing confused I respect it
shout out gloves shout out to gloves man
a real Niner fan shout out them Rams
when last time the Niners won a ring I
hope I hope y'all make it Super Bowl
this year I'm not a Niner fan so who
who's your team from
Ariz [__] out thank God cuz we're trying
to get the number one pick I was so glad
you guys won oh my god oh hell no you
like the Cardinals I'm from Arizona man
it's a everything you're a Steeler fan
you beat us in the Super Bowl you know
who I [__] just met at Drees and took
a picture with Antonio holes at Cox
sucker [__] he was out of bounds I
told him I said you were [__] out
that wasn't hey bro y' Ain y' ain't had
[__] since Big B got into that car we
with Y last this year though yo shout
out to Big Ben man he's a rapist yeah
Big Ben Ben rapist Burger you know what
I'm saying I don't even know what you're
talking about that ain't our quarterback
no more shout out to Ken pick it's a
[__] bum yeah but we the we we 7 to4
then we send y'all don't You' got a l
from us too no not this year I don't
think we' played yall this year when the
last time yall won a ring 2009 also I
don't care I want to lose every game one
last time y'all w a ring Never Never
Happened we're the Clippers of the NFL
bootle Kev here hey shout out to King
pom man we want to show them some love
uh listen I've been I feel like
enlightened recently uh since we've been
working with King p man the cleanest
smoke organic all natural no tobacco and
this is what's dope about King pom is um
they have these Turpin infused tips and
what I love about them is whatever
flavor you're into like these are the
red rain energy drink flavors I'm big
energy drink guy right so you stuff what
you need in these bad
boys hit that tip you're going to get
hit with a nice shock of flavor boom
that's the uh pink lemonade also these
are the natural boys but I'm G show you
what it looks like rolled up all right
let's take a peek in here we got the
king palom boys
here this what we're doing all right now
if you go to King pom.com it is the
holiday season you want to take care of
somebody you love you want to take care
of yourself you deserve to be taken care
of yo 50% off right now use that promo
code bootleg it's either 50 or 40% [__]
I probably should know that I think it's
50 though either way 50 or 40 bootleg
king pom.com or you know go to 7-Eleven
they got
at there any of your smoke shops in your
hood whatever it is wherever you're at
pull up to your smoke shop get you some
King Palm one more time organic flavor
no
tobacco it's lit also can we show some
love to our family at harden man shout
out to hardine man look if you're in
Vegas you got to pull up you got to say
take me to hardine right now I need to
go to harden they're going to take you
they're going to get you situated Hardin
Las Vegas the best cannabis uh
dispensary I've ever walked into in my
life the most craziest selection of
Premium cannabis in the entire world I
mean that place smells like
God's uh sweat it feels it just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Harden Las Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to Hardin
vegas.com and when you're in Vegas make
sure you pull up to harden baby yeah I'm
a Lakers fan though
nah see n wouldn't say the Lions or us
at least we've been to two Super Bowl no
we've been to one Super Bowl on NFC
Championship the clipp the Clippers
haven't even made it to Western
Conference okay it's a little different
so so the lions are the uh Clippers of
the NFL yeah it's a little different you
know but you know shout out to all the
LA [__] on the Clippers oh so let's
get back to um so uh shout out to YG
obviously shout out Westbrook shout out
James Harden how how hard was it cuz
there was a stigma that like y was just
trouble and I know it affected his
pockets for a while but I feel like you
guys have gotten on the other side of
that for the last five or six years very
very successfully but there was that era
like when you guys were on tour with MC
with MC Miller you know what I'm saying
like who was El was someone else was on
that tour was it Travis Porter Travis
Porter so random that was bro you know
what's so crazy bro that was one of my
favorite that was Travis Porter is a
group three guys three guys yeah three
guys Oh I thought man cuz what's that
song they used to have then he they had
a lot of hits
theyig Migos before Migos going lie I
thought that was like one person I never
making like La [__] low key they had 100
BPM [__] going up out here yeah but I
was I'm wondering like what did y'all
like was there a certain point in time
where like you guys had to like really
be like hey we got to chill with the
overreacting or cuz the brand is leg
like I feel like y's done such a good
job of transforming his brand to being
like high fashioned like he moves like a
superstar now and not like a a [__]
gang member from La I just feel like you
know you get to a point and you start
seeing things for what it is like and
you have to move a little different for
the respect because it's like you can
get people from other states they can
talk the same [__] they can wear Rags
they can do all this [__] but because
they're not from La it's
like it's it's part of the art but
because we from La it's like oh they're
really that it's like I don't know that
[__] that [__] just be kind of crazy to
me cuz I'll be listening to records it
be like bro that [__] said way crazier
[__] than we said on swoop and it's like
how but it's just I feel like it's the
world stigma because it's like when you
think about gangster you think about the
West Coast for sure like so it's like
you just automatically attach his name
to whatever has came from the west coast
and then it's like well he was he like I
mean listen y'all was moving around
[__] but but this the thing though
but what we you got to ask yourself
right
no no no but how many deep at
at for trouble was it 40 deep but were
we looking for trouble no but y'all was
moving but think about this though how
how many people Young Jeezy move around
with I have no [__] idea at this
point when y signed a young jezy and we
moved to Atlanta we thought that we
moved around deep he was moving around
with 100 people everywhere he went yeah
so it's like but because we from La it's
a different stigma no for sure for sure
but like at the same time I just think
like bro even if you look back and look
at all them incidents like we know who
we are and where we come from we never
looked for trouble but if you came to us
with it like I think too like what we
supposed to do turn he's in a position
now where he's kind of like hey bro like
this dude is like I said the biggest La
rapper we've had in the last 10 relevant
like 15 for sure you know what I'm
saying so I think it's like when you
think of YG I think like he's he gets
held to an unfair standard here
sometimes amongst like some of the young
like generation I'm feel like it's easy
to hate on y or a point be like why
ain't you like I'm like bro YG has been
holding this [__] down
for years outside though not on the
internet but like for real holding it
down like it's not like he switched up
and started doing like weird pop [__]
like no this is like this guy's been the
same dude [__] for sure and uh you can
go buy his clothes at Zoomies you know
who else can say that you know but you
know they don't talk about that he had a
collection in Barney they don't talk
about that it's like what type of La
dude you know has real La clothes being
sold in Barney but people don't they
don't put that up like oh can't believe
YG had a show and Barney like oh yeah so
Rapp y was also involved in such and
such yeah that was I mean were you who
was with when he when he got shot were
you there nah me and mustard um wasn't
there but we had found out and we went
straight to the hospital man was it's
been a scary time bro in La that was a
crazy that was a crazy but is I I still
say that to say is like I don't just put
that on La no but I mean if we think
about the incidents that have happened
with hip-hop artists in the last six
seven years A lot of them have happened
here not all of
them yeah but it's like in what
situation I mean there's plenty of
situations so many people there's so
many rappers I know that have been
robbed that the blogs don't know about
th% but you know the crazy [__] I know
so many rappers who go to Atlanta get
Happ in Atlanta too they ain't no blogs
right it happens in Atlant go to New
York and get ra robbed downstairs of the
studio right it happens everywhere it's
like bro I don't think it's a la I think
it I think what it is is here everyone's
hanging out in the same on the same
[__] Street for the most part so if
like you're a Jack boy you know where to
hang out at you know what I'm saying
like Atlanta's so like no it's the same
[__] because like this look bro how how
many people get killed at Linux Mall how
many people get robbed L Lin Mall active
put us there L Mall Linux Mall isn't
Linux Mall isn't in the hood that's a
suburbs right that's like [__] getting
robbed at the Beverly Center or getting
robbed on melr it's the same you feel me
just like because it's Hollywood but
every it's it's like this whole stigma
bro that gets [__] up is like bro when
you come to La we got downtown we got La
we got Hollywood the
valley I'm not even talking about the
valley shout out to to the valley though
but we got La we got downtown and we got
Hollywood when you go to these other
places you got the city and you got
downtown right that's it suburbs but
yeah no for sure you feel me so it's
like where is it happening at where the
stars but like bro [__] is getting
robbed in New York and Tribeca [__]
getting robbed outside the Supreme we
don't hear about it as much exactly yeah
for sure um all right so you're album's
on the way yeah what's it you have a
name you got a name for the album tell
them yeah my side of town all right on
me
coming from from the East side yeah
coming soon yeah my side of very soon
probably like in a week or two oh [__]
okay uh and then you you your Studios
called creative creative sounds Crea
sounds just had our 2-year anniversary
it was [__] crazy I had G herbo ogz
baby Stone gorillas RI and gutter
Bracken perform in my parking lot and
you uh can tell me a y album's on the
way soon a sexy red single on the way
soon very very soon sexy red single
might come before this this this
interview drop okay well I mean the
video shot that means it's it's time
it's go time same for gut every every
video shot you know and he's editing
them himself smart guy hey man all you
artists out there take a page out of his
book stop [__] depending on other
people edit your own [__] yeah I got my
own camera too go on YouTube and learn
some [__] for sure that's all you got to
do well look we're gonna drop a
freestyle with this guy uh so make sure
you uh go check that video out and um
shout out to you guys' ig's gut BR on
all platform how you you don't spell g u
d d a b r v c k i n yeah the V is where
yo follow me everywhere at Pusher Rod um
follow the studio at creative sounds
recording I'm here real wests side [__]
boom I'm an East Side [__] from the
West Coast
fire appreciate you guys watching hey
this interview was brought to you by odd
Soxs baby the holidays are here and the
people who you love deserve the flyest
socks the most comfortable socks in the
world oh these Scarface socks oh look at
these things look at these Top Ramen
socks what are we talking about whatever
you're into WWE Scarface uh The
Godfather [__] Transformers Power
Rangers Ghostbusters Breaking Bad uh
Coca-Cola hello you know I mean they got
the socks for them and they are the most
comfortable socks in the world get some
odd Sox Basics on your feet and than me
later odd Soxs of official.com use the
promo code bootleg save 20% off at
checkout for the holiday season
appreciate youall watching